طائرات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي تقصف منزلا في
بيت حنون كما انها استهدفت مواطن كان يقود
دراجه هوائيه في رفح جنوبي قطاع غزه
المعلومات المتوفره الى حد الان هبه نحن
نشاهد على الهواء الان صوره هذه الغارات
السنه
اللهب ترتفع والدخان يرتفع في السماء اذا
هذه صور
للغارات في شمال غزه وردتنا قبل قليل تفضل
هبه
نعم نعم نعم
ما اكده شهود عيان الان ونحن نشاهد في
شمال عزبه بيت حانون هناك غاره استهدفت
ارضا زراعيه وكان قبل ذلك هناك حسب شهود
عيان استهداف لدراجه لا نستطيع التاكيد لا
يوجد اي مصدر رسمي تحدث عن هذه
الغاره او حتى اي من
اجنحه
المقاومه تحدث عن استهداف لعناصره نحن
نتحدث عن شهود عيان تحدثوا ان
احدى هذه الغارات اصابت
دراجه ناريه لا نعرف مدى صحه هذا النبا
حتى الان ولكن مازلنا نسمع اصوات انفجارات
من القبه الحديديه وهذا ما
اننا قبل قليل شاهدنا انطلاق عدد من
الصواريخ في سماء قطاع غزه ايضا عندما
نتحدث عن رؤيتنا لهذه الصواريخ في السماء
نتحدث ايضا عن سماع صوت اطلاق لقذائف
صاروخيه في المناطق الحدوديه وعاده تكون
هذه
القذائف الصاروخيه باتجاه المناطق القريبه
الى الحدود في البلدات والمستوطنات التي
تقع ضمن ما يسمونه منطقه غلاف غزه بالتالي
هناك تواصل في اطلاق الصواريخ والقذائف
الصاروخيه من قبل المقاومه الفلسطينيه
وكانت سرايا القدس قد اكدت بان استمرار
استهداف اسرائيل للمنازل
واستمرار هذا هذه الغارات الاسرائيليه
سيواجه باست القصف وعلى جهوزيتها
واستعدادها لاستمرار هذه المواجهه او هذا
التصعيد لاشهر قادمه وكان هذا
التصريح وهذا البيان مؤكدا لما صرحت به
فصائل المقاومه من تحذيرات لاستمرار
استهداف المنازل وكان هذا التصريح في بيان
الغرفه المشتركه للفصائل الفلسطينيه الذي
صدر مساء امس تحدث ان استمرار لاسرائيل
لاستهداف منازل المواطنين سيتم الرد عليه
وقالت بعض الفصائل بان
تعمد اسرائيل باستهداف المنازل والاحياء
السكنيه سيكون الرد عليه بتوسيع نطاق
اطلاق الصواريخ في المدى وفي الكم
وبالتالي هذا ما نشاهده من هذا التصعيد
وتيره هذا التصعيد في ساعات الماضيه ولكن
هو ليس جديدا نحن اعتدنا في على مدار خمسه
ايام من هذا التصعيد العسكري الاسرائيلي
على قطاع غزه ان تمر عدد من الساعات يكون
فيها الهدوء نسبي او تنخفض وتيره الغارات
ولكن ما بعد ذلك
تتلوها ساعات من تكثيف هذه الغارات
وبالتالي اطلاق الصواريخ من قبل المقاومات
الصيفيه في الساعه الاخيره ونحن نشاهد هذه
الصور من بيت حانون قبل قليل عن استهداف
غاره لهذه
المنطقه كنا قد شاهدنا السنه اللهب وهي
ترتفع في السماء والدخان يتصاعد لا يزال
الموقع الذي استهدف غير واضح قد يكون منزل
اذا تم استهداف منزلا في بيت حانون قبل
قليل هبه هل تؤكدين هذه المعلومه
كان هناك غاره بالتاكيد ولكن كان هناك
غاره في شمال بيت حانون وكان هناك غاره في
منطقه بئر النعجه في جباليا وهذه الغاره
التي استهدفت بئر النعجه كانت استهداف
لاحد المنازل نحن نتحدث عن سياسه
اسرائيليه باتت واضحه وفيها تكثيف
لاستهداف المنازل منذ اليوم باليوم امس
يوم تصاعد حسب الصور يبدو بانه اهداف منزل
وتم هدم المنزل بشكل كامل وهي سياسه
مستمره شكرا لك هبه سنعود تفضلي تفضل
الملاحظه فقط للملاحظه بان الطائرات
المسيرات الاسرائيليه تستهدف هذه المنازل
بعده صواريخ ويكون هناك اضرار جسيمه في
هذه المنازل وفي المنازل المجاوره ولكن
سرعان ما يلي هذه الصواريخ
غارات من طائرات حربيه اسرائيليه تقوم
باطلاق صواريخ كبيره وبالتالي قد يكون
الغاره في على نفس الهدف ونفس المنزل في
ساعه واحده يطلق اكثر من خمس او ست صواريخ
هناك ما يتحدث عنه البعض بانها صواريخ
ارشاديه اي تقوم الطائرات طائرات
الاستطلاع باطلاق عدد من الصواريخ على هذا
المنزل ثم في اقل من من يعني تقريبا نصف
ساعه ربع ساعه حسب الوقت الذي يعطى لاصحاب
هذا المنزل يقوم تقوم الطائرات
الاسرائيليه باطلاق صواريخ ثقيله وبالتالي
هدم هذه المنازل ولذلك نشاهد ان الغارات
تتكرر على المنازل منها من صواريخ مسيرات
تحدث اضرار كبيره وقد تحدث ايضا اصابات
بين المواطنين ومن ثم
يلحقها غارات من قبل الطائرات الحربيه
وتقوم بهدم كامل لهذه المباني هذا للتنويه
فقط لان الغاره قد تتكرر في اقل من ساعه
عده غارات على نفس الهدف ونفس المنزل